good morning winner take a deep breath
visualize the Mount
your success and look down at everyone
who's ever doubted you [ __ ] those losers
[ __ ] them in their stupid [ __ ] faces
[Music]
talk to her she's got a really cute
smile Amy to knows how many girls are
gonna be up your vagina not sure every
time I come to visit you you're gonna be
scissoring and different girls dude
this ring is not a thing don't knock it
into benighted don't knock it until
you've tried it it's the last day we got
you through high school I need to go
VanDerveer budget numbers man we just
graduated head off to college that
should do it
right I can't hear you I can't
soundproof glass we have to go to a
party to me what nobody knows that we
are fun
they didn't party because we wanted to
focus on school and get into good
colleges and it worked
they're responsible people who partied
also got into those colleges I'm
incredible at hand jobs but I also got a
1560 on the SATs we haven't broken any
rules name one person whose life was so
much better because they broke a couple
of rules awesome he broke our rules Rosa
Parks naman else who's in the Anthony
dammit
hand sanitizer that traps tic-tac mace
listen it is very important that you
keep the safety
what the [ __ ] is this oh my god can I
say
[Music]
well this seems excessive shotgun just
kidding I don't have one don't see we're
having a date night why it's funny your
parents think we're boning but you do
have is fashion we are going to show
each other how much we care about each
other well probably just do a korean
face mask I don't need to know all the
words
[Music]
you